wenn ihr euer eigenes Gemüse auf dem
Balkon anbauen wollt dann könnt ihr euch
hier richtig was abschauen Platz ist ja
bekanntlich auf einem Balkon ziemlich
knapp deswegen ist es richtig clever
wenn man wie hier die Töpfe stapelt oder
das Gemüse in irgendeiner Form vertikal
anbaut Gemütlichkeit ist natürlich auch
oberste Priorität auf einem Balkon so
das ist der richtig schön habt und nutzt
auf jeden Fall auch das Balkon Geländer
um da in diesen Balkonkästen hier Gemüse
anzubauen wir haben auch ein Hochbeet
gebaut aus Paletten das war überhaupt
nicht teuer da können wir auch große
Pflanzen wie z.B cool anbauen und
wusstet ihr dass sie auf eurem Balkon
sogar Obst ernten könnt das ist unser
Apfelbaum der blüht gerade aber auch mit
der Gemüse Ernte geht's jetzt langsam
richtig los wir haben erst vor ein paar
Wochen angefangen den Balkon schön zu
machen und zu bepflanzen und natürlich
gibt's noch die ein oder andere
Baustelle bei dieser kurzen Zeit hat
sich der Balkon schon in so eine
Wohlfühloase verwandelt also folgt uns
wenn ihr mehr Tipps und Inspiration
wollt